un silence de mort pèsent sur borodianka
après le départ des troupes russes de
cette petite ville à 70 km au nord ouest
de kiev les forces ukrainienne craignent
de découvrir des cadavres de civils par
dizaines 26 dépouilles ont déjà été
extraites des immeubles éventrés par les
bombardements selon les autorités après
charles vi
si le déblaiement des décombres à
borodianka a commencé c'est encore plus
épouvantable là bas encore plus de
victimes des occupants russe que se
passera-t-il lorsque le monde apprendra
la vérité sur ce que l'armée russe aa
fait à marioupol là dans presque toutes
les rues on assistait ce que tout le
monde a vu à bout de chats et dans
d'autres villes de la région de kiev
après le retrait des troupes russes la
même cruauté les mêmes crimes terribles
les secours des blessés graves à la
recherche de corps
les habitants eux cherchent leurs
proches c'est une course contre la
montre les survivants pourraient
toujours être bloquées sous les
décombres
ma mère mon frère ma belle soeur sa mère
et son beau-père sont toujours là ainsi
que d'autres personnes qui étaient là au
sous sol
il y avait beaucoup de monde aux étages
supérieurs là-bas des enfants aussi et
je suis sûr qu'ils ne sont pas sortis
la procureur général d'ukraine et des
organisations non gouvernementales sont
venus constater la situation dans les
rues de borodianka leurs investigations
ne font que commencer aucune scène
d'horreur comme dans la ville voisine de
butcher à et ses corps aux mains
ligotées n'a encore été diffusée mais
les juristes sur place accuse déjà les
forces russes de crimes de guerre